字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
觀眾朋友注意喔
各位同学们大家好
哇 过完年了
只是好想大家
今天台湾股市有点精彩
有点开高走低
有没有看到
在这边最高33,663点
对不对 坐坐
33,663点
结果
哎呀
不对 不好意思
34,212點
不好意思
來來來 衝來衝來
大家好
我哲哲
今天直播不能NG
我很想念大家
今天最高34,212點
大概漲了差不多六七百點
很多人覺得會漲八百點九百點
哲哲你不輸到九百點嗎
嗯 我有說過喔
我今天要不要播VCR
我有說過最大問題台積電ADR過年期間沒漲
所以是其他股票漲喔
哲哲有預告在前面喔
哲哲不論對貨錯有預告在前面喔
先跟大家講
我們來看一下好不好
今天大盤指數在這邊
哇塞 創一個新高
其實這個算蠻誇張
因為過完年後很多人其實
還在休息 還在放假
結果快一兆的成交量
然後來到34,212點
如果在去年11月有人跟妳講說
36,000你應該覺得他瘋了
那時候大概26,000點而已
現在轉眼鏡已經是36,000
怎麼看這國際股市
我還在強調一件事
今天36,000基本上是沒問題的
你們應該不會懷疑吧
重點是4萬點會到
有機會
可是他現在問題就是一樣
長太快
可是這幾年你會發現到
可能甚至AGI的產生
我已經講過了
像自駕車你看馬斯克多狂啊
美國法國有沒有通過
他就先生產自駕車
我都不懂他這個是噱頭還是怎麼樣
也算很會炒股票
那飯著要幹嘛
要給誰買
不管啦
你先放下去再說啦
先生產下去再說啦
反正他覺得自信會通過自駕啦
以後都不用
以後完全就不用什麼
不用煞車
不用方向盤的車子
你今年就可以買到了
多誇張
所以AI這時代真的來臨了
只是你不了解而已
還有Gamini時代真的也來臨了
最新Gamini 3.1
哇 很多人也是都覺得很恐怖啊
哇 在這邊他已經有一般人的推理能力
跟邏輯能力的
甚至比一般人的邏輯能力更好一點
那所以也造成股市真的是很誇張
因為其實像我現在也是
基本上從歷史故事
我喜歡問歷史故事
到醫學嘗試
到去日本旅遊的時候
哇 比如說日本旅遊嘛
你可以去日本旅遊
比如假設你去日本旅遊
假設這個台北
這樣子問喔
以前像我不常開車的人
比如說台北你要去台中
台北你要去台南
由北到南有什麼交流道
我四個小時的車程
請你幫我每兩個小時
要一個交流道
或每一個小時要一個交流道
也有個休息站
他都幫你規劃好了
你只要想到任何事情
只要你會懂的發問
絕買都可以完成它
春晚的機器人也是一樣啊
哇 會打罪拳
會打罪拳欸
然後很多人覺得
哇 中國制的不可靠
沒有
中國機器人真的厲害
好不好
Seed Dance的影片也真的厲害
而且我不是要告訴你
你不是說我中國好
我就說台灣不好
這兩回事
就像台灣的關稅也談得很好
也有人說那台灣關稅
現在川普關稅違憲了
失領了
要重彈
No
沒有這一回事
台灣的關稅不可能重彈
台灣沒有這本錢
台灣沒有這個本錢
違背美國
台灣也沒有這個本錢
去跟中國打戰
這是懂嗎
這是台灣現實
現實社會的基礎
大家要了解我的想法
我的個性
我個性這樣子
我沒有特別針對什麼政黨色彩
我覺得我講話都是比較中肯
所以因為比較中肯
我可以遭遇到台灣股市
三萬
有機會三萬六
甚至四萬
可是哲哲你不是說
年後有機會大跌四天點怎麼看的
今天漲167點喔
今天開高走低喔
我期貨空單我是賠錢的
我現在有轉餐
有轉餐
轉餐的好處是什麼
好處是說
因為這個現在的期貨有點
正價差高達200點
現在大盤33773對不對
期貨33961
大概190點
在解釋是喔
就是現在期貨比大盤多200點
當然期貨是有點堵喔
不論是會員朋友或粉絲
你要做期貨你一定要了解風險
跟股票不一樣
你懂嗎
所以你要了解風險
那我當然大部分會員
都是股票會員
期貨只是小菜一盤
大家參考
那很多人想要知道說
哲哲你不是跌4000點
今天不是要進展了嗎
你說不論怎麼樣你要做多嗎
我要告訴大家
今天還沒有進展
你今天開高走低為什麼進展
啊 機體都噴出去 我怎麼進場
有些股票一開盤掉下去怎麼進場
沒有必要
而且我要告訴你 講話同時喔
事業給我齁
納斯達克的期貨還在跌
小納
有沒有
小納有沒有看到
小納斯達克
小型納斯達克期貨
叫小納
以前如果這個在跌
跌超過1%對不對
基本上台灣股市會跌
今天沒有
那我今天放輕鬆啦
小納
如果小娜老了會變誰
會變什麼職業你知道嗎
變和善
和善
你知道什麼變和善嗎
老娜
對沒錯
小孩你怎麼懂我這笑話
出個國不錯
變聰明了
所以小娜斯達克
現在等於台美脫鉤了
那台美脫鉤要不要
那變成是跟韓國股市一樣
現在就是氫軟體重硬體
三星海力士狂飆
那如果哪一天三星海力士沒有漲了
那不好意思喔
那台灣股市就會跟著韓國股市一起回黨
我要告訴大家 現在還是規律率過高
當然
今年有機會
實現很多的 比如說AI機器人
AI自駕車
然後AI的軟體
你看都進展很快嘛
影片都進展很快
這些都有機會去實現
可是也不可能一瞬間全部漲完了
所以韓國股市聽說現在也很多人在做空
尤其散戶啊
做空比例很高
那今天韓國股市到最後是跌了嘛
我們看最新的
我很想大家大家有沒有想我
看一下齁
好 我們順便看一下大家留言
以後啊 我會比較有時間跟大家多聊天
因為之前我的時間都卡在那個
瘋狂股市福利社
現在也會當製作人
但少錄影還要差比較多
先跟大家講
來我們來看一下
韓國是後來又拉起來一點點
漲0.55
小納斯達克大概跌0.8%
今年我認為4萬點是有機會的
因為現在漲到3萬4
4萬點是有機會的
好不好
4萬點是有機會
先跟大家講清楚
來
那我們大家留言一下
看大家
大家有沒有想哲哲啊
來
那今天可是有個黑天鵝啦
就是缺GPT OpenNI大減支出啦
好不好
來來來
這個呢 來來
進額是-5264
就今天期貨的空單是減了5264口
但這不一定準喔
因為今天是結算日
這看不準
現在目前為止看起來應該是32929口的空單
因為現在有一個粉絲
緊張是第三個發言的
所以你們盡量趕快前幾個發言
前幾個卡位
兩點半一到的時候趕快卡位
我大概影片兩點三十到兩點三十五會播啦
就兩點三十之後大家卡位
就一個皇冠了
今天空檔增加了5224口
這不一定
要看等一下三點多的數據
等一下四搖
看三點二十有沒有最新的數據在跟我講
好不好
這不一定
問專業
問請問就是我專業的
我是台灣算前幾批
前兩 前幾批
考量期貨分析是排照的
好不好 OK
來
空檔有加空
看起來
空檔有加空但不一定
因為今天是結算日
有可能加空的空檔被截掉了
知道嗎
OK
楊強哲哲 謝謝大家
哲哲你有大賺嗎
嗯
應該這樣講
留著股票還不錯
蠻強的
但是還是
有些空手的人
到目前沒有進場
來
我們來看一下
國具嘛
有沒有 春田製作所不是說
華信科不是說怎麼樣
說要那個
要漲價了嗎
你看國具戰場
很厲害
國具戰場很厲害
展上去
跳空展停板
留兩天的下影線有沒有
這算很厲害的手勢圖
有沒有
那我们今天有恭贺简讯看一下
当然我有讲过了嘛
我基本上我都有减码一半
我说有些股票减码一半
就是所有的资金部位减码一半
就是比这一千万
我现在是大概五百万的部位
恭喜2327国具
股价大涨喷涨停
准备再赚坡赚新高
哎
我今天不应该我讲话
你们今天要小韩还是要依依
没关系就去依依好了
先女生好了
小韩我怕点语率会下滑
来 依依来跟大家say hello一下
大家好
來 我們唸一下簡訊
好 幫我唸一下
好 2月23 禮拜一
今天的簡訊
恭喜2327國具股價大漲噴漲停
準備債賺波段新高
MLCC龍頭春田考慮調漲價格
我持續看好他手上持股獲利虛報
恭喜大家
手上持股獲利虛報
趕快趕快
你要找個分析師已經Ready好的
來 另外一個有沒有看到
跟恭喜
都是被動元件的 唸一下
我嗎
對 就是你
不然小孩嗎
小孩你唸一下
好
好 2月23號禮拜一
今天簡訊
恭喜新花怒放2492華興科
股價跳空噴漲停
即將重返月線之上
產品報價有望持續調漲
我持續看好他
手上十五報好報勞
恭喜大家
三十五報好報勞
過年有沒有去還沒玩
伊伊有沒有去還沒玩
沒有
沒有 去日本啦 忘記了
對
吃的好嗎
好
住的也好
有去泡餐嗎
都有
那個是第一天的好像真的很大嗎
有一千比以上聽說
有
而且很多池
很多池啊
吃幾個池是不是
對
我們吃都吃不錯
吃到他們都吃不完
每天就是餵豬行程
所以有相信嗎
一個人平均要差不多十萬塊差不多吧
相信
我們還那個公司等於
還舉辦了兩個晚宴對還等於是尾牙等於有兩次的感覺啦好不好還抽都亂抽一通最大獎本來1月的時候已經有抽獎了
100萬
100萬日圓
然後去日本
好像又有30萬的
都一直在抽
一直在抽
這跟大家講
當然其實我覺得
同仁們心情好
他們才能幫我們選出標股
是不是
有很多研究人員是一樣
好不好
所以還是股票也有
我就是至今現在卡到50%以下
目前為止也沒增加
還沒有權利做多
我講實在話
好不好
那期末有做空
有轉餐
至今在賠錢
可是我跟他們講的風險要做好
你不能全壓
因為他有賭博性質
我都有跟會員朋友講
這是期末會員
股票會員基本上就是
目前為止
就是部位還在減少中
沒有 今天也沒什麼
今天基本上沒什麼動作
可是有想要進場
但是我還是怕很回檔
好不好
還是怕回檔
這跟大家講
好不好
股票有做多的
少數做多的股票
你看都蠻強的
這是華興科
那為什麼
為什麼被動元件會強
等一下再跟你講記憶體好不好
現在被動元件
全球MLCC 行漲
日本韓國大產
產人蠻窄
台產受惠
你看
這個你不要看哦
你不要看三星電機
三星電機
三星的相關子
相關子公司哦
春田製作所
就是考慮調產
三月底前決定
所以AI熱潮認為
已經持續三年了會增加
所以春田製作所是龍頭
三星什麼都做
包山包海
受險醫療
冰占夜
什麼都有
好不好
樂園什麼都有
從出生到死亡
三星都有包
好不好
所以被動元件也有包
我講是開玩笑嗎
不是剛才是認真講的話
你問韓國人就知道了
所以三星決定看被動元件
看春田製作所有沒有斬價
他們再決定
所以這個就長了
那它為什麼會長?
基齊嘛
第一個
之前被動元件回檔蠻深的有沒有看到
是不是
長上去後回檔蠻深的
你說深有啦
有差不多回檔差不多
一成多快兩成
來這是國具
然後
華新科
16843212
也快兩成
快兩成
沒有沒有
128 有有有回答兩成超過了
回答兩成超過了
我真的是不太喜歡放假
我發現放假以後我會頭腦會變蹲
你們會不會這個發現
我昨天晚上去重訓到快10點半11點
很怕睡不著
我想太多了一下就睡著了
來
再看一下
所以那個被動元件回答比較多
那這記憶體濫潮一定是ok的啦
因為你看喔 如果以後Cdance
然後以後你要儲存一些影片
儲存一些資訊
像他都知道
我的Gamer來他真的都知道
都知道我是分析師的
然後知道我是商務人士
很龜毛
很追求品質
他都從我的個性來幫我
求一個最佳解
那他以後你習慣他以後
就可以再打廣告了
但目前為止沒有
為什麼目前為止沒有
很簡單
很多人說沒有收入
不是沒有收入
而是Google故意不要收入
為什麼
Google要先讓你習慣他
他先利用免費
來打敗所有的對手
所以不用考慮這 AI 泡沫不泡沫
就是今天German來
German的對手open AI減少支出
純粹就是因為他輸
TrackGPT 他輸Google
那Google為什麼不收錢
你覺得他沒有收入
他沒有特別收入
是因為他不需要收
他要先把對手把open AI打敗
open AI看起來現在就是有點快被打敗了
懂我還說什麼嗎
來
懂我們說什麼
來我們先跟大家聊聊天
從員工就是帥
謝謝大家
請問一下川普其中學取是不是極其可為
有啊 但極其可為啦
大家都不支持他啦
是不是
ABF 賣飛到吐血
能就好玩了
之前那個星星啊
我還記得去年
低到70塊每個人在網路是要罵我
那現在漲到400塊
我就說 喘喘你怎麼賣掉了
300多塊賣不行嗎
唉
摸摸頭顧的分析師都很強
對啊 不一定要唱喘喘
我們每個分析師都很強喔
開高走低
對啊 幫我們訂閱分享喔
按讚 按讚 按讚
今天直播人數2700差不多
大家回來了齁
來
不知道住哪間飯店喔
哪間我們忘記了
第一龍本齁
還有溫莎
溫莎
去東野湖那邊
還有住JR
Tower
應該都不錯喔
你們去查吧
我都好像平均一晚到快一萬塊對不對
對
有去查嗎
那個時間快一萬塊對不對
小孩有去查嗎
有有有有超過
對啊 那時間都快一萬塊
超過囉
都快一萬塊囉
我們都住一萬塊以上的飯店喔
嗯
過完年有沒有新的搶錢方案嗎
有啊有啊
現在要推廠喔
有你們現在加入我
你們現在加入趕快加入啊
不用不用
最好的搶錢方案就是我要斬價了
好不好
228以後要斬價了
228以後要斬價記得
好不好
就跟大家講了
3月份就斬價了
228之後就斬價了
就到這禮拜六我就要斬價了
會不會要斬價
我就跟大家講
我說你去問一下所有的業者
那個最
現在好像最低薪水好像是從28000
是2萬8小安
對
我記得2萬8
今年開始2萬8
你2萬8一個保全能源喔
就是好像是工作12小時保全能源喔
薪水都4萬2了
保全能源
你去任何一家
所以台灣基本上二不死啦
只要你願意努力工作
真的
都變4萬2了
那公司要給多少錢
健保 勞保
退休金保一保至少20%
42,000 x 28
不好意思就是5萬塊
所以基本上保全能源5萬塊
如果開
我的Uber司機
那麼認真開
可以賺7到10萬塊
我想是真的
所以
為什麼要講這個東西
我討厭過年
我真的同好變笨
對啦
有啦
小人家幫我接著話
一一幫我接著話
所以人事成本很重啦
好不好
所以要增加要增加費用
啊哲哲什麼都漲價
股票也漲價啊
所以你最傻就把錢放在銀行
現在是高通盟時代啊
你把錢放在銀行的人最傻
最笨
最笨最傻
放在定存最傻
真的真的真的真的
啊你說哲哲有部分放定存
你說你有錢有的要命齁
你有十億二十億
你放個幾千萬放個一億
那當然沒問題啊
你沒有特別有錢人
想賺大錢你把錢都放在定存
最傻最笨的
都不投資最笨的知道嗎
好不好
OK
這跟大家講
仇治長是我兄弟曹西唯一偶像
我是很多人偶像沒關係
謝謝大家
你知道去北海道怎麼去看台灣人多不多嗎
你知道
不知道
不知道齁
就是去北海道看哪個地方台灣人最多很簡單
看有沒有認出我來就知道
我們那最後一天在那個三井凹累對不對
對
一堆人認出我來害我不得不戴口罩
前幾天還好
保全上班時間長又沒什麼休假
對啊對啊保全是很辛苦啦
我只告訴你他們人事成本現在很重好不好
什麼行業都很辛苦
保全也是很辛苦的
對啊
這跟大家講
我們給保全人員
像姊姊是在這個重大樓當主委啊
就在中上東陸延吉祥這邊當主委
姊姊也是對他們不差
我還親自
我很少送人家禮物耶
我還心裡把自己那個很好吃的牛大湯
我還給他們美人一盒
還包個紅包
這個也沒有人主委
還自己套腰包的啦
也包了好幾萬
全部加起來也包了好幾萬
所以我絕對沒有歧視保全人員
我覺得他們很辛苦
每個行業
保全員行業
醫療行業
各行各業
都令人尊重
我只是告訴大家
成本很重
所以我們要增加會費
這不會是那種歧視別人
如果歧視別人
我紅包幹嘛給
對不對
這個那要主委給人家紅包的
根本就不需要
沒錢賺還給紅包
我們的工作人員
當主委又沒錢賺
又辛苦
來
那我們來看一下
這個納斯達克這邊看起來有點小破底
這個納斯達克在那邊拉起來對不對
可是今天如果要跌1%
他又有點破跌的情況
這台灣股市真的是沒有跟非半指數在
跟納斯達克在跟的
所以現在有點漲多
所以這樣就是等記憶體有沒有鬼故事
如果記憶體有鬼故事的話
要讓你OpenAI減少支出
大家會怕
當然OpenAI減少支出
純粹就是被Google 咳嚓掉了
那這個行業很恐怖喔
它可能像Netscape一樣
你記得這個名詞
玩警
就是以前
哇 這個網頁
IE網頁贏了
IE網頁的叫Netscape
現在缺GPT
感覺很厲害
沒有 真的有多高人
會用多用GEMALINE
差太多了
智力差太多了
好不好
這跟大家講
所以我要講的就是說
現在這個開第一槍
大家會有人緊張
但那個緊張
我覺得不會緊張太久
趁著緊張
這個緊張
如果股市有回產的時候
你好好跟我一起進場
過年搶錢方案
到時候我再推出
好不好
不用了啦
反正現在就是一個優惠方案
過完以後
228以後
就是小小漲價
好不好
人事成本提高
來看一下
OpenAI
看一下
這新聞大家有沒有看到
就是學生資出減半的
不只減半的 減六成
有看到舉手
做投資
等一下
你看OberAI對不對
本來2030年預估營收
要突破2800億對不對
有沒有看到
你看啊
如果2030年
如果是先不支持
之前喔
資本支出是1.4兆
現在變6000億啊
變多少
變大概打了打四折
呵呵呵呵
四折多
那為什麼你去想一件事喔
如果到2030年OpenAI還沒賺錢
但是美國股市很變態
只要夢想你能說服觀眾
你能說服股民的話
虧10年沒關係喔
亞馬遜之前這樣子喔
聽懂嗎
虧個好幾年都沒關係
所以可是問題是
你6000億也是虧啊
你2030年的時候你就算你
你支出6000億
問你啊
支出6000億
營收2800
怎麼賺錢
還有其他成本喔
是運算支出就這個喔
是不是
相關其他的費用呢
其他的折究是怎麼樣的呢
是2030年前的喔
他減少資本支出
還是大虧
可是不減少呢
人家覺得差太多了
一個是2800億的收入
你光是資本支出
還不含其他的支出
就一點失照了
大家覺得這個在誇張
所以減少了怎麼樣
減少從1.4兆
這個箭頭有點畫錯了
從1.4兆到6000億的一個資本支出
大家會覺得怎麼會資本支出減少那麼多了
可是不得不
因為到了2030年才2800億而已
我認為不會那麼多
為什麼
你記得這個行業
我告訴大家很現實
這是我確定的
AI這個行業
尤其像這種AI軟體這個行業
從來同樣到尾就只有第一名
第二名
第一名跟第二名而已
第一名吃香喝辣
其第二名吃大家剩下的粥跟湯
湯湯水水
第三名吃渣
吃粪
哦 這樣講太低級了
吃渣
好不好
吃只能
就吃剩下的
收水
我講話很直接很狠
所以這種行業都這樣子
手機也是一樣啊
蘋果加三星
都是蘋果的賺走的
蘋果加三星賺走99%的利潤
你看三星
你現在看Sony有在做手機嗎
買不太到了吧
華碩已經停止做手機了再買嘛 以前有四五千怎麼辦現在記憶體現在記憶體的成本那麼重不可能有什麼幾千塊的手機然後又不錯的你懂嗎所以我要告訴你手機業者也是這樣
只有第一名跟第二名
基本
那這種軟體
基本上也只有第一名或第二名
甚至可能只有第一名而已
你懂嗎
就像比如說你看到的是Netflix
沒錯
我會訂Netflix
我也會訂DISNEY Plus
我會訂DISNEY Plus
喔 算不错
我还会订MOD
我什么都看
过时过完年
过完年我想看什么东西我都看
来
OpenAI 2030年转换
营收目标及运算支出
到时候这个我觉得它会被
现在目前看了
我觉得它除非有大幅度的进展
不然绝对会被GEMANA
卡掉掉
好不好
这个预告在前面
所以资本支出不得不减少
来
关税加到50%你就能进场
关税看起来不会到50%
因为现在法律
现在川普就是
你让我说这个法律违宪嘛
那没关系啊
之前有个法律说我最多就15%嘛
可是现实好像一百多天而已
所以现在
所以现在川普很聪明啊
他单说怎么用15%来做个甜蜜点
看看
为什么台湾跟日本韩国都15%
因为这个
他像克这个对手关税的
遵循的法律
有可能违宪
他用另外一个
合法的法律
可以15%
最高法律
川普之前可以手一遍乱加
加到100%加到200%
可是实际上的法律
给他最多的附与他
是120天
然后15%的税率
所以他就是
他觉得至少最合法的是15%的税率
超過了基本上法律是不認的
所以他很簡單
他到最後還是給你課15%
在他合法範圍裡
他知道300%的稅率
500%的稅率
對中國700%的稅率
或者50%以上的稅率
都是假的
都沒有用的
所以他最後給你談判到15%
然後要你們
台灣人
韓國人
日本人
繳很多的關稅
還要繳很多的投資
給他
這樣懂嗎
OK嗎
AI感覺很難一家多大
我覺得有第二名
應該有第二名第三名
第四名以後就不用想了
基本上第一名以後就差很多了
好不好
去北海道旅遊
有沒有遇到投資長
好可惜哦
好嗎
現在看到我了
好不好
川普會在近日攻擊一籃嗎
這我不知道
對戰爭我有時候策略
有時候我預測能力還好
好不好
外資未平昌
潛了30852口
所以四爺
所以大概空单还增加3000多口而已
是要给我一个最新数据
好不好
所以最新的空单大概
是不是
还是我搞错了
我想问一下
是不是空单应该是大概
只减少3000多口
请是要回答我
每831也没很多
满手现金好手进场
关税最后不是转到美国消费者身上不是吗
是啊
關稅最後就是九成
有做個研究九成
所以到最後是誰告他
Costco
是美國產商Costco
豐田
一些汽車的
或者是說
美國這些進口
就是產商告他
因為產商告他
因為成本的增加很多
你懂不懂
OK
夜盤在展的
我們看一下夜盤
展100
不是
展94點
我們講的好像
长几百点一样
叶盘在长很正常嘛
好不好
我先看有没有突破
这边34 30
但是随时都有机会突破
我觉得现在起来
就是非常猛
非常猛
好不好
但是我还是觉得
有点风险
我就跟大家讲
不差这一两天
好不好
这基本上就这一个礼拜
顶多再玩一个礼拜
我就要做多了
因为空太
因为说好实话
股市本来
股市九成的时间
九成五的时间
不是盘整就是长
如果今年股市强成这样子
连回谈都不会谈
那我也认了
那该做多做多
好不好
你记得认去该做多做多
不要想太多
好我们看一下
那现在期货展求几点
我觉得还好
还好
不过增加差有300点
注意一下
增加300点有好处
快300点
好处是什么意思
好处就是说
基本上
期货的人愿意做多
代表是期货的人看好
做出期货的人有秘密
或者他知道什么秘密
或者他觉得
台灣股市非常看好
基本上可以增加差300點
覺得股市太好
另外一方面也是這種壞事
太熱了
熱到明明漲300點
這麼不划算的交易
還是有人要做做起貨
看你怎麼解讀
OK嗎
來
這兩個都可以解讀
好不好
空單實際增加3187
3187塊有沒有
沒有 四角有跟我講的有沒有
我跟妳說我剛才心算能力還算不錯啦
算過完年後覺得會頭腦變笨
都這樣子
這時候殘教效應
說我不太適合放太久
就是假期超過三天以上
超過四天
我就會覺得第一天錄影
我會稍微比較鈍一點點
不會到笨啦
鈍啦
所以川普關稅可以不要理他嗎
好不好
基本上對全球是利多
因為他最多只能15%關稅
不能增加啦
他罵那些大法官嘛
他有本事就直接在違憲啊
他又不敢
對不對
那基本上
他也都谈好了
他很聪明
所以台湾为什么急着在
过年之前谈好
不是应该说美国急着在台湾
在过年之前
谈好这一批的关税
为什么
因为如果没有谈好的话
川普最多也只有158关税而已
台湾就可以慢慢的耗证一下谈判
那你说台湾现在已经谈好了
可以重新谈吗
没有这个空间
不要想太多了
好不好
没有这个空间
你会发现
画面给我
九人会发现
很多人就说
你一定支持
哪个政党的
在野党的
我告诉你
你真的看我太浅了
有时候我说中国好
中国真的是不错
可是我告诉你
我说话是
就是论事的
什么意思
在野党立委
真的不用去强调说
重新跟美国谈判
台湾没有这个立场
不可能
没有这个本钱
美国人要我们做什么
做什么
唯一能做的是
打个折而已
他要你做的方向
就这样
美国人叫你说
之前单兵三四个月
叫你单兵一年的
你能改变他的想法吗
照做吗
照相修改法律吗
是不是
是啊
所以不要想太多
你要冷怒川普吗
我觉得
这再一档立委
这个就傻了
为什么就傻了
因为我跟大家讲
如果哪天
哇塞
台湾要怎么样
OK
我就对台积电克随
然后台湾股市大跌以后
就有人罵在野黨立委說
你為什麼要跟川普重談
說千萬不要
當然講多數是變政治的
你們聽得不開心
因為每次講政治就有人不喜歡
就有人喜歡
不需要
所以我關注什麼不想講
基本上沒什麼影響股市的
除非台灣真的有人傻傻去阻擋
川普的關稅
說我們要重談啦
反正違憲要重談
我跟你講
這社會上
你們記得一件事
我以前一直聽不懂那句話
歷史
是強者在寫的
你贏了
隨便你寫啊
對方是好的又怎麼樣
你把他打贏了
我跟你講
那些敗官也死
基本上都是你人家寫的
什麼意思
基本上是一回事
違憲是一回事
川普有100種方式可以搞台灣
懂不懂
所以基本上不會改了
好不好
台積電算掉怎麼談
你這個就是負面的
我跟你講一件事
今年台灣股市會賺那麼多錢
你們會賺那麼多錢
你們要謝謝台積電去美國
富產
沒有沒有第二個選擇
我覺得張中某選人選對
魏哲家身段軟
沒有比他還身段軟更軟的CEO了
所以川普這個人
你要跟他講話
你就是要找一個身段軟的
你不要刺激他
他有一個好鬥個性
這樣子也是一個好鬥個性
就有人要激怒我的時候
我就變李維了
就變激怒李維
不是不是
有人要激怒我的時候
那我覺得好鬥個性就會出現
就是你跟川普這個人講
你不需要去跟他刺激他
就是這樣
你不要刺激它
你就會談判到很好的東西
OK嗎
要開始做多了嗎
你要的話要找我啊
找我來找我啊
哎呀沒有關係啦
只要買低軌外星概念股
我買的股票應該有低軌外星概念股
可是我不是因為低軌外星概念股去買它
懂我意思嗎
就是有些股票就扯上邊的
就漲上去的
可是我不是因為低軌外星去買它
OK嗎
AI還是
還是怎麼樣
還是未來的趨勢啦
好不好
那我們來看一下
這是新花怒飯嘛
有沒有看到
有暫停喔
就是華新科 新花怒飯嘛
花的新 新花怒飯
國具 暫停喔
今天的股票精彩
3374精彩有沒有看一下
真的很精彩喔
精彩 看到
來
念一下 念一下
那個1念一下
來
好
2月23 禮拜一
今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精彩
股價已經連四天大漲
準備再賺一年新高
我們多次買進最高已經大賺52%
我持續看好他手上持股報好報勞
恭喜大家
精彩不錯好不好
精彩看起來噴出去囉
注意一下喔
然後樊薰好像也展示不錯
是不是
你看一下2344華班店
你看華班店大展對不對
可是他最後沒有鎖暫停
我真的很shock 到了
3260 微剛
也沒有啊
所以你說記憶體強嗎
是黑K
記憶體很強也沒有到多強
你知道嗎
還有那個
立基電是677電視
677立基電
也有點開高走低耶
所以記憶體我先看一下
我先認真看一下
因為我本來還以為滑板那種暫停嘛
鎖死嘛
我剛已經在忙 尾旁我就沒看它了
我要講的是說 記憶體實際上它沒有暫停耶
目前為止有記憶體暫停嗎
你們可以 我看一下比較強勢的記憶體
我們現在馬上看
沒有耶
記憶體沒有暫停耶
沒有耶 所以說記憶體真的很強嗎
也沒到很強 我本來就是記憶體很強 還好耶
真的沒有很強
那有沒有可能就是已經是強弩之末了
就是現在斬記憶體是斬那種實際的記憶體
記著記憶體 什麼意思
要跟HBM有關係的
所以三星還立誓還在漲
美觀還在漲
然後
Sandisk還在漲
這真正的 而不是說
哇 因為台灣的記憶體比較跟
比較邊緣啦
不是實際的 不是HBM
或DDR5的題材 比較少啦
我說過 真的比較有題材是
6239的歷程嘛
這個歷程是做封測的
HBN
AI的記憶體大概是HBN
做封測的
說好實話
封測的轉型就轉比較少
不是不能長會長比較慢
所以現在是符合我說的
記憶體最好轉的一段已經沒了
所以你如果真的記憶體要轉大的
我還不如巴不著它回檔
這樣的時候巴不著它回檔
你看一下
5347世界先進
你看這邊回35%
一反彈就反彈個20%
有沒有到
反彈個17%
聽懂的意思嗎
所以你要找
你真的記憶體
你要說折折那不如拉回
要用力做多
你不先參加會員
到時候我用力做多怎麼辦你一直問我你為什麼不先參加會員呢好不好這是我跟大家講我不要只講強的我要講一些弱的聯發哥今天有點這樣弱很誇張所以你不要看今天台灣股市很強
他強中有點透弱
可是我要告訴你
今天36000看起來是輕鬆達到
甚至38000我一開始喊了40000
都有機會喊到
我自己喊36000最多40000
好不好
那第二個
0068GB
如果這一次真的那一天
喔 攒上去有沒有知道
哪一天美再噴出去了
好不好
請你們告訴自己
台灣股市有崩了
有真的回彈三四千點了
然後美債噴出去
我最後一次再跟你強調
趕快換
可是是因為不小心發誓了
說不然我不當分譯師
我要賺兩千代方才走
不然我是真的要出掉了
我才不管賺賠了
反正我第一次有賺
反正換台灣50就好
好不好
記得接下來如果美債有少賠的
美債再一次噴出去的
趕快換台灣50
OK嗎
不要說只是沒錯
好不好
OK
不要說只是沒錯
我都預告在前面了
這個尾串也不該暫底
所以今天你不要看
台灣股市好像很強
並不強
我看一下
你看今天威剛
也還是在月線之下
有沒有
真的比我想像中弱
因為我本來一直想說
今天利基電很強
結果是啊
利基電真的很強
因為利基電聽說
就是要
台灣美國日本合作
不是要突破三星
跟海力士的一些重圍
这话题
不然你看
你说滑斑店
叠声反弹喷出去
好啦
可是今天居然
展停板没有锁死
还有望宏2337日
望宏也是这样
展停板没有锁死
真的很乖
你们感觉大会有点边拉边出
我不敢算说
可是记忆体我目前为止
我比较倾向于拉回进场
不拉回就算了
就不要买它
那我就买拉回的华星科
我买拉回的变动元镜
你看今天為什麼被動元件暫停
因為被動元件之前沒什麼漲
哪有什麼漲
哪有回檔
就這麼簡單嘛
股票每天都可以做
不要擔心
只能休息一兩天而已
休息一陣子而已
也不是休息啊
就是我最近沒有
我還是有股票啊
我今天華新科
國巨還是我們的股票啊
精彩也是我們的股票啊
只是我沒有全部加碼而已
我還沒全部用多
因為還沒有權利又做多
因為我覺得還是有回檔的可能
那當然我要告訴你
我原本就
原則上就這一周
再延再延
延後就要下一周
我不要再延太久了
因為如果這個行情
因為它很輕鬆化解的
空頭的賣壓嘛
之前不是跌個2000點嘛
那拉起來
那真的是非常凶狠的走勢
可是我要告訴你
就是因為這凶狠
你隨時來的時候
回答可能性
好不好
者者不敢說100%對
但我做好說而打算的
好不好
這我跟大家講
我很想念你們啊
好不好
這跟大家講
好認真解說
者者目前沒在有算嗎
我第一次算1500萬
你忘記了
現在沒有
現在我看有沒有賺
我看應該是賠啦
我賠多少
是賠啦
怎麼可能現在賺呢
美債是真的
等我一下喔
我連那個損益
都不知道在哪邊的
你看我多久沒看損益
我看一下喔
等我一下喔
我看美債我賺還賠
賠多少錢
等一下喔
賠600萬啦
1.1沒錯吧賠600萬對不對
對
賠600萬啦
那還好啦 因為之前賺1500萬
現在加900萬啦 賺900萬
只是很遜啦
因為台灣如果台灣1.74億
犯台灣50的話都可能賺1億的
看你怎麼說
可是只是還是有買40型的ETF
來
空單加暴再回答
這有可能
好不好
還差多少
2600萬差很多耶
還差大概
17%
那個要崩盤才行
那個要回答7000點
這真的很溫柔
是不是又打瘦瘦針嗎
你們知道我最近又打
最近又打
又打
這跟大家講
可是這個不能慘打
慘打太多
我會有點憂鬱
我不喜歡不開心的人生
來
這每個人體質不一樣
像我就是喝水也會胖
喝水也會胖
我一去北海道馬上胖了3公斤
馬上回來打瘦瘦針又好多了
好多了
當然我不建議
我不建議
很多人問我說
蛇蛇
那你有沒有推薦什麼東西
那個藥品我不要亂推薦
你自己問醫生
好不好
除非你這個沒辦法
只是當然身邊很多人在打
那個親朋好友問我
我會跟他講
可是因為我不認識你
我不能跟你亂推薦
可是你說睡眠比較好的
第一個吃吞味基素嘛
國外有些可以買嘛
第二個就是
當然這個吞味基素
台灣現在好像買不太到
你可以繞來繞去啦
這個我就不多說
我找合法的
就台灣法規
美國根本就可以買推文技術
你吃鋼胺酸鎂
Costco在賣
好不好
還有最前
這兩個加起來
就讓你睡眠升很多了
我就睡眠很多了
好不好
這個誠實公開損益
分析是第一人
我賺賠都買有獎
對啊
OK
夠帥了不要再打了
太帥也不好我知道
太帥也不好
來
記憶體抱著就好了
我覺得不一定
現在投資買房還是買股
當然是買股票
我都說要四萬點了
你給我開什麼玩笑
是什麼時候買
現在買房子最傻
台灣的房子
很多人不是說
哇 去日本買房
開始有人講去日本買房
持有稅很貴
台灣持有稅也不少啊
不是 台灣持有稅還好啊
可是要付一堆錢啊
而且現在轉手麻煩啊
為什麼
因為現在很多人都不買房地產啊
而且你有錢啊
我跟你講假設你身價
你有幾十億啊
假設你有幾十億
你會買1億的房子嗎
做投資嗎
不會
為什麼不會
脫手很難脫手啊
你知道
現在要買1億的房子
你要帶個
你
基本上你要現金拿個七八千萬的
無聊喔
那我直接去買台灣50就好啦
買台積電就好啦
賺多快
你1億的房子賺到2億
要多久
我看10年你都賺不到啊
你1億的台灣50
到2億
我告訴你幾年就可以達成了啦
五六年就可以達成了啦
你自己看台灣50嘛
那跟你開玩笑啊
要買房 現在買房最傻啊
還原
像78嘛
你看2023年28還不齒雷
都快三倍了
兩年前28塊了 你自己看
你自己看
去年最低點35塊到現在都一倍了
不用
對不起我說錯話了
不用五年
三年就可以三倍了
你一房子可以到三億嗎
喔 我說你炒房宅
還上新聞呢
氣死人了
知道嗎
好啊
福利是要換古怪教授
對啊換古怪教授喔
好不好
可是我會當製作人
別擔心
我會支持他
買房要自住可以
但投資別人
對 沒有錯
自住
哇 你自住
我聽你這樣講
買房子自住
我要自己住的
那聽你這樣講
房地產以後很難脫手
你要自己住
你管他那麼多
等房子跌下來再買
人生真悲哀
但以前我也像你這樣子
有點悲哀啦
哎呀 我以後再享受
我跟你講
過了30年後再享受
你知道20歲的體驗
跟50歲的體驗差很多
先跟大家講
只是還沒到50歲
我怕大家
以前我當分析師的時候
20年前我怕大家知道我年紀
怕大家知道我年紀太年輕
现在我怕大家觉得我太老
有点不一样
OK吗
OK
能享受就享受了好不好
现在建商的资金都在
黄祥建设不是买一堆台积电吗
又卖了又买了又卖了
建设公司都是这样子的
很聪明啦
搞房子没有用
好不好
头长那么帅已经不要再打收拾生
OKOK我是太胖才会打
不用担心
这只有几千房子
心音少賺三根斬亭
你看人真好玩
留一點給人家賺啊
好不好
先斬900點在哪
你們的標題真好笑
我有說台積電一定會斬900點嗎
我說風險是台積電斬
斬那個台積電跌
台積電過年期間沒有斬
你看台積電真的跌
台積電跌是個風險之一
好不好
差不多了
今天這節目要差不多結束了
好不好
我要告訴大家
來啦
我認為36000
基本上很輕鬆到了
去年就跟大家講了
只有我跟大家講
百萬粉絲可以見證
那今年我們
我要告訴大家
你看一下這些簡訊喔
看一下我們藍雅科
賺2040%
星星賺160%
這是最近的績效
景碩賺120%
而且都獲利出清了
星星園賺110%
利基電賺97%
南電賺93%
金豪科90%
力程60%
世界60%
艾普51%
華班電36%
好不好
起雞這些沒有
起雞這些是賠錢的
其他大部分
絕大多數人最近績效
有最近這兩個月進場的股票
大部分都是賺錢的
絕大多數人都賺錢的
這會員都可以見證
那接下來我現在是一半的
一半的資金在股票
甚至有些人稍微更低一點點
大部分是一半的資金
那一半的現金
我等你來給你操作
我們有些會員是這樣子
等你來
哲哲有沒有年後有沒有搶錢方案
到時候我告訴你
你現在不會來參加我們了
你過年後就算搶錢後方案
應該說3月過後的搶錢方案也會貴
會貴很多
因為人事成本要提高
好不好
不論對貨錯者一切一切都要前面
台股漲得有點多
韓國股市也漲得有點多
好不好
隨時拉回
當然拉回它不是一定
當然我覺得有可能
不論最好最壞
我都已經想好了
反正我該進場還是得進場
所以你趕快跟我進場去做多
那今天有點開高走低
可是你如果是空手
你應該更希望趕快回等的時候
跟我一起用力去做多
不論對我錯我一切一切優高的前面
今年有機會3萬6甚至4萬點
你不要到時候我這個績效又在複製
哇90% 100% 這是實在的獲利績效
而且是普通會員的獲利績效
到時候我在複製的這車好恐怖喔
為什麼沒有參加那個便宜的搶錢方案
為什麼沒有參加
為什麼要漲價後台股漲價了
會費漲價後我來參加
你會很後悔
所以不論對我錯者者一切一切優高的前面
去想想看人家什麼東西
歡迎來電洽詢080668085
或是加入來私信我說這車
我要赚大钱 我告诉你
我会努力告诉你
接近所能来帮你赚大钱
谢谢各位 拜拜
如果觉得我们影片很有趣的
觉得有深度的
还蛮准确的
欢迎按赞我们的影片
订阅我们的影片
按小铃铛
记得按全部接收
还要加我们的LINE
以及加我们的Telegram
我们的LINE跟Telegram
都是全台湾最大的一个财经频道
谢谢各位
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家